[Music]
[Music]
good evening i'm alexander rose i'm the
executive director here at the long now
foundation
the
season is upon us that about half of
long now's general fund comes from this
time of year so i'm obligated to remind
you that you know
many of you are members and thank you
that's about half of our general budget
the other half is really uh donations
that come in in this time of year so if
you're interested in a bottle at the
interval or if you do do end of year
philanthropy uh is greatly appreciated
[Applause]
um i'm sorry i have a cold
and
it affects my voice and probably my
brain
uh if anybody wants to shake my hand
show me your elbow
recently we had um david grinspoon here
talking about the anthropocene tonight
we're talking about a good anthropocene
and our speaker will get to the good
part but anthropocene is still
question how you pronounce it but a
question of
what its size is so greenspoon's thought
was
it's a cognitive planet now and that's a
change as
profound as any that life has done in
the past and life in the past has
separated not just epochs talk is of
making the anthropocene an epic kind of
like the whole scene epic which is just
10 or 11 000 years old
he says no i think it's an eon
and the shortest eon the most recent eon
is the phanerozoic which dates back to
the cambrian explosion which maybe we're
having a sort of a cambrian explosion
lifetime now in various respects
and that was 540 million years ago
so that raises the deeper question of if
we are getting into an anthropocene
eon
it's really important to probably get
the early stages right
because the leverage is enormous as you
go out that kind of distance
and nobody has looked closer at the kind
of leverage it takes to get it right
than our speaker elena bennett
thanks stewart
great
so
i want you to picture
standing here
in north america
in the middle ages
sometime between the 5th and 15th
century
let's pick the year a thousand thousand
years ago
this is cahokia it's a large native
american city from that time period
probably the largest one
it's just outside what's now st louis
if you want to get really into this you
can either look at the image or close
your eyes
and i want you to think about
living there
what did you spend your time doing
who did you interact with
and how
what did it smell like
what did it look like
what did it feel like to live there
and when you have that in your head i
want you to imagine talking to one of
those people that you interacted with
over the course of your day
and trying to explain
the world
of today
and how we got here
how do you explain the arrival of
europeans people you probably didn't
even know exist
existed
how did you explain the impact that
those people had on you not only in
terms of disease and warfare but also on
your values as a culture and your
understanding of your values
how do you explain the combustion engine
the automobile
the cities the size of st louis
skyscrapers any of that the way we live
today running about at high speed
chasing after pieces of paper money that
denote all kinds of power and value
it's really hard
to imagine that the cahokians of a
thousand years ago could have told
stories
that explain the next thousand years
that's what i want to talk about today
so before we head on our journey into
the future though i want to think a
little bit about
today
and where we are so let's start in the
anthropocene a new geologic epoch in
which humankind has emerged as a
globally significant
and potentially intelligent force
capable of shaping the face of the
planet
so what does it mean to live in the
anthropocene and i find the best way to
do that is to think about the past at
least to look back to say well what did
it mean to live in the holocene
so this graph shows you the conditions
on earth over the last 100 000 years
through a proxy that explains global
temperatures that blue line is the proxy
that tells us something about global
temperature
it covers a hundred thousand years it's
about half the span of human existence
on the planet
about half the time that we've been here
with roughly the same mental and
physical capabilities that we have today
so
what do you see when you look at this so
one thing you should see right away is
that temperature bounces around a lot
and that causes crisis for people
and every time we have one of these
crises people move so you see about
about 90 000 years ago or 80 000 years
ago we leave africa
in a temperature crisis
about 60 000 years ago in another
temperature crisis we colonize australia
come to europe 40 000 years ago in
another temperature crises all of these
movements driven at least by temperature
crises
and then
in the last 10 000 years we get to the
holocene this remarkably stable period
and about a thousand years into this
period of stability we develop
agriculture and from agriculture comes
literally everything else we know about
human history the greeks the romans the
enlightenment the industrial revolution
and and on and on so this relatively
stable period
11
700 years long of the holocene it's the
only state of the planet that we know
for certain can support
modern human societies of the kind that
we have today and we don't know what
happens after that
we know that we're headed out of this
and we know that the stability of the
planet is being fundamentally challenged
but we don't know what happens after
this
and that brings us
me as a scientist all of us as citizens
to what i think is a fundamental
question
how can we how should we live
in this fundamentally different world
that is headed out of the holocene
and what i'm going to argue for today
is that i think we need an entirely new
paradigm an entirely new way of thinking
about
our place on the earth that integrates
some sort of continued development of
human societies
and maintenance of the earth system in
some sort of resilient and accommodating
state that allows human societies to
live
and to develop that paradigm i'm going
to argue that we need visions of what
that world is going to look like
what it's going to smell like
what it's going to feel like and what
our role is as people
in that world
okay
so first though i want to take one more
look at what it means to be living in
the anthropocene and i'm going to do
this through the paradigm of this thing
called planetary boundaries and this
emerged from the ideas on that last
slide this idea that the planet's
stability
uh
which is important because of its role
in in societal development
is fundamentally under threat
and so to investigate what aspects of
stability might be threatened we examine
nine different boundaries or earth
systems for which we thought there would
be fundamental thresholds
and we picked them because they regulate
stability of the earth's system through
some sort of interactions of land ocean
and atmosphere
so let me walk through what these are
and then i'm going to walk through a
little bit of how those have how the
state of the planet has changed relative
to those through time so if we start
right up at the very top with climate
change
we set this boundary to be 400 parts per
million of co2 in our
350 parts per million co2 in the
atmosphere
uh a boundary which we've now
crossed as we head over 400 parts per
million
uh
co2 in the atmosphere
if we move now clockwise around this to
novel entities this is emissions of
toxic compounds like synthetic organic
pollutants radioactive materials
but also things like genetically
modified organisms nanomaterials
microplastics things that persist in the
environment for a very long time
next we have stratospheric ozone
depletion
the ozone layer in the atmosphere that
filters out all sorts of harmful
ultraviolet radiation
from the sun
and we
have set a limit for that
atmospheric aerosol loading which
affects cloud formation and weather
patterns including monsoons
ocean acidification so about a quarter
of all the co2 that we emit
is ultimately gets dissolved in oceans
and there it forms carbonic acid which
decreases the ph of surface water and
that increased acidity changes the
available carbonate which changes uh the
building block that's used by corals and
other shell building animals to build
their shells
biogeochemical flows of nitrogen and
phosphorus that are used as agricultural
fertilizers
again now we reach a boundary that we
have crossed with this one we
set this boundary based on keeping fresh
water systems intact
and we're currently at double to triple
the the boundaries for those freshwater
use
this is
set because human pressure is now the
driving force in determining function
and distribution of global freshwater
systems and the boundary is
environmental flows that maintain
critical function
of those systems
land system change which is maintenance
of ecosystems
that are are out there forest wetlands
other vegetation types that are now
being converted to agricultural land and
what i want you to notice primarily
about these is of these nine systems
that we think are
fundamental to maintaining the earth in
a stable state we have crossed in yellow
and red
four of those nine boundaries right now
so we've crossed the boundary for uh for
land system change biosphere
integrity
which is about species loss for
biogeochemical flows and for climate
change
and if we walk through how this
uh
how this happens through
time
um in this nice set of slides that was
actually made by the same people who
made that
the long short that we just watched we
can see that when we start in
pre-industrial times we have a lot of
question marks about where we're at
but no significantly crossed boundaries
by the 1950s we're already crossing the
boundary for biosphere integrity which
is set at maintaining 90 percent of the
species on earth
by this point already we've lost over 80
percent in some parts of the world
we get slight increases in the 1970s
in some of those
boundaries
we head into the 1990s we cross
significantly more including the
stratospheric ozone depletion
which is interesting primarily because
when we get to today
we come back
off of that one so that's a very
interesting boundary to me because it
shows that there are some at least that
we're able to cross at least regionally
and then take collective global action
to to address
okay
so
that concludes the depressing part of
what i want to talk about tonight i hope
um
and and and and it is
it is depressing and it is a little bit
uh a little bit disheartening
um and so what do we do about it well
this this might be what we want to do
about it right you know sit in the
corner of our room plug into some
virtual reality machine and and forget
all of it
but i'm not here to recommend that we do
that tonight
um
another thing that people sometimes
think we should do about it is well we
can tell really scary stories about
collapse and just try to scare the heck
out of people
and and maybe that will will do
something and there's there's a lot of
uh both scientific and popular visions
of collapse and hardship and and those
at least to me really underscore the
idea that
that's a pretty popular approach
actually to handling our fears about the
future there's lots of these
visions
i don't recommend that approach
either
in part because those scary visions
create a lot of fear and anxiety but
they don't
give us anything they don't tell us well
what is it that i should what is it that
i should do about that they do a lot of
what not to do
and even on the not to do it sometimes
is a little bit unclear but but they
don't give us uh what what should we do
and and i think that's the reason why
these negative visions haven't always
created the kinds of action that we hope
that that the fear-mongering is going to
create and
to me that's really important for a
couple of reasons you know one is our
children and our grandchildren and our
great-grandchildren
are going to live in this world they are
going to live in the anthropocene and as
stuart was saying
the the way that we start that is a very
powerful force for for how that's going
to look hundreds or thousands of years
into the future
and the second reason that it's
important is that the visions of the
future that we're presented with and
that our kids and grandkids are
presented with are going to shape
our decisions and our actions and the
way that we
feel about the world and so to me
doing things that expand our range of
positive vision are it's just incredibly
important we don't right now
at least to me have a clear and viable
answer to the question
what do we want the world to be like
in 50 years or 100 years or a thousand
years
so the project that i want to talk to
about tonight is all about
generating that vision or generating
those visions because it's probably not
one vision of what we want that that
world to look like
um and that's important because we can't
we're facing all of these problems that
make us want to sit in the corner of our
room but we're not going to solve these
problems using the same thinking that
got us into these problems we somehow
have to generate some sort of novel
uh visions it's this it's today's
thinking that got us into this problem
let's generate some new thinking to to
try to get us out of it
okay
one more idea that i want to introduce
first before i get into what some of
those visions of the future might might
look like and this is subtle but it's a
really important i think shift in our
thinking so we used to tell this story
that there were these things on the
planet called natural ecosystems and the
people were basically
in the way destroying things causing
problems mucking it up
and what i want to do is suggest a a
subtle but important shift
to a new way of thinking where people
are part of the biosphere where there
are not ecosystems and social systems
but social ecological systems of people
and nature
that are evolving together
and i'll just point to this
which
was
done by georgina mace who's a
biodiversity scholar who essentially
traced the history of our thinking
i think really nicely to point out why
this shift in our thinking is so
important so
what she's saying here is that in the
60s and 70s uh the majority of the
thinking and especially the framing of
conservation was approached as this idea
of nature for itself so if we can just
create some protected areas
to maintain wilderness and just get out
of the way
things are basically going to be okay
and that carried us that sort of
thinking carried us through the 60s and
70s
in the 80s and 90s people get a little
bit more worried and we start to do this
well nature despite people
so here now we're worried about
extinction we're worried about
population over exploitation and people
generally believe that nature is
surviving
despite us
that shifts again in the early 2000s
to nature for people
and here this is the idea that well
maybe we can encourage more conservation
by convincing people by pointing out all
the things that nature does for us so we
prospect for new medicines in the forest
there's all kinds of ecosystem services
that that we get from nature like food
and fresh water places to recreate
aesthetic beauty spiritual well-being
you know maybe if we work on valuing
these and really appreciating and
understanding those maybe that'll work
for conservation
and and finally now we're shifting
uh i think or need to shift maybe to
this world where we start to think of
people and nature together where we
understand this as a world that is full
of social ecological systems where
people in nature are intertwined and
where the focus is now
on management that is maintaining the
resilience and the adaptability of this
system
here's why this framing is important
if we think of ourselves fundamentally
as being outside the system
then our goal is just to get out of the
way
and and
for one thing i just don't think that's
the right way to think about this
problem
and for another thing
we're too big there's too many of us and
our impact is simply too dramatic to
just
get out of the way no matter how much
we might want to we're never going to
set aside large enough swaths of the of
the earth for conservation so
you know i think of this in some ways
it's like a you broke it you bought it
situation you know we we own it now
we're here
um and we need to do something about
that and and i would argue that we need
a new
humble
way of thinking about ourselves and our
role where we are part of this system
but but not the only part of this
okay
so
this feels hopeless
can feel hopeless we've crossed four out
of nine planetary boundaries scientists
are screaming at us that we're changing
the earth's system
we're on our way fundamentally to
crossing more of those boundaries we
often don't even understand them we're
still arguing about our role on the
planet and how to protect parts of it
so question that
follows me around
all the time is
how do you move forward how do you not
just sort of stand in one
anxious place unable to take action but
how do we move forward and how do we do
it in a way that retains
hope
that empowers us to bring about the kind
of better world that we want to live in
here's why that's important to me hope
is incredibly important hope engenders
agency
and motivation to change and agency in
turn engenders hope because it creates
possibility
so for example it's hope
by creating hope for escaping maybe a
poverty-stricken neighborhood that we
encourage students to study in ways that
facilitate that escape or even
facilitate someone's dream of not just
escaping but coming back and improving
the neighborhood that they came from
which creates more hope which creates
more agency which creates more hope
okay
before i move on to hope completely
i'm going to i'm just just going to turn
a little bit back into hopelessness and
then i promise i'll be done um
this is this problem um
it's only to say this that i don't want
to belittle the hopelessness or pretend
like it's not there there is really good
reason for concern we're seeing
unprecedented
pace of anthropogenic change we have a
lot of concerns but
if we extrapolate current bad trends
we run the risk of being self-fulfilling
people base their actions on what they
believe about society and what we expect
for the future so if we only talk about
problems then we only see problems and
then we start to believe that only
problems
lie in our future and we lose our hope
and our agency
so
this is my message for the day
the future doesn't have to be bleak
and in fact we can point to an emergence
of
new thinking
innovative ways of living
different ways of connecting people to
nature and people to other people that
bode really well for the future
as people are becoming aware of threats
to society and threats to nature we see
people and individually and groups of
people increasingly engaging in
strategies that aim to create a more
just a more prosperous a more
ecologically diverse world what we might
call a good anthropocene and i'm sure
that you all have seen that change
around you this is
little things that are done by
individuals or by small groups that are
aiming to change the world or some part
of it you know even creation of this
this group here of the long now
uh by itself is an example of a way that
we're trying to think about time and
change our actions on the planet
and inspirational stories
and inspirational visions can be a
really key component
of that sort of transformation to
society helping to shape the very
reality that they forecast
if the stories that we reach for when
everything seems to be coming apart are
ones that lead on themes of disaster on
fragmentation on breakdown on stories
that offer no hope of making it over the
chasm to safety then it becomes so much
more likely that we're going to find
ourselves confronting just such a
scenario but
if on the other hand we have stories
visions signs
weak signals so-called pockets of the
future in the present that are positive
that are inspiring and purposeful
they have the power to drive us in a
different more hopeful kind of
transformation
so in science we call this kind of
storytelling scenario building so this
is the practice of telling
several imagined stories about the
future and how the future might unfold
and it's been used for a long time in
the military community in the business
community
in international science communities to
explore different alternative futures
and to help us improve capacity to
respond to and even to shape the future
so if i give you an example one of the
early business adapters of scenarios
with shell oil and then they were very
small company in the 1970s and oil
prices were low and shell as a minor
player was busy developing different
scenarios as a way of increasing their
corporate adaptability sort of staying
on their toes i kind of imagine lots of
worlds so we can be successful no matter
what comes about and they happen to have
one scenario in which oil prices rose
dramatically
it was controversial
it was even radical um but it wasn't
unrealistic
and they led that led the company to
change some of their practices to sort
of hedge against high oil prices
and for those of you who are around in
the 1970s you know that of course what
happens is 1972
opec forums and prices rise really
rapidly and really dramatically and
shell was one of the few companies that
was able to take advantage of their
adaptability to respond really quickly
to this new world order
so that's an example of how this kind of
scenario planning might work in a
business sense
and scenarios have been
used in the global scientific community
as well so the millennium ecosystem
assessment was the largest ever
assessment of the state of the planet by
over 1300 scientists from
dozens of different countries
all around the world and as part of
their efforts one of the things that the
millennium assessment did was develop a
set of
four different
scenarios about the future
so those scenarios looked like this so
there was a scenario called global
orchestration in which there was a
globally connected society it was
focused on global trade on economic
liberalization
uh reactive to environmental problems
but not proactive to them really a world
that's focused on reducing poverty and
inequality and investing in public goods
as a way to solve problems
there's a world called order from
strength this is a regionalized and
fragmented world very concerned with
security and with protection
emphasizing primarily regional markets
and paying very little attention to
public goods and again reactive to the
environment
we had two more scenarios one called
adapting mosaic that featured watershed
scale ecosystems that are the focus of
most political and economic activity
with strong local
institutions and ecosystem management
with a strongly proactive approach to
ecosystems
and another proactive one techno garden
with this globally connected world
relying strongly on environmental
technology
so these are interesting
but
all of these and nearly all of the
scenarios that have been developed by
the global scientific community
um
have these visions that that i would
argue they're interesting but they're
kind of poorly articulated they end in
these kind of utopian fantasies they
often overestimate conventional
ideas like technology or localism we
overestimate the the
power of those conventional strategies
to bring about real change
and they lack a lot of the detail the
surprises the transformations
the things that are the hallmark of how
real history
has
unfolded but we can't be too harsh on
these the goal of these scenarios wasn't
to tell positive stories but simply to
understand pros and cons of of the world
around them
one outcome for me of of being involved
with with building these was this
realization that none of these solutions
works perfectly so for example poverty
alleviation is great for some things but
causes irreversible environmental
problems when it comes to fast and local
solutions are great for local problems
but leave us
in the lurch for facing global problems
like climate change
and another realization for me was that
trying to invent stories about the
future from whole cloth especially
starting globally from the solution
wasn't really all that effective you
know to me the stories
felt a bit shallow they left out a lot
of things that i knew to be important in
the world that i was living in they left
out all kinds of cultural diversity for
example they left out political economy
and questions of power
they left out important differences in
world views and how those might play out
in the future
and really importantly
they left out things like trust
hope
fun
those are things that affect
all kinds of the ways that we interact
with each other and with with nature
so in fact if we think about the future
it's likely to be
radically different from today so think
back to that example of cahokia at the
very beginning
when we think a thousand years out into
our future that future is likely to
involve fundamental alterations of human
environment relationships across a
variety of different settings changes in
values assumptions cultures
world views even power relations that
affect social norms and behavior
but envisioning that future is hard
right how do you envision different
cultures different world views that
you've never even thought of
before
we haven't done such a good job of that
with the global scientific community we
can draw a little bit on this kind of
utopian fiction
um but the issue with these at least for
scientists like myself is
they don't have to be realistic
they don't have to be scientifically
rigorous
they can feature some of the things that
we think are important so trust and fun
resilience hope
but i am seeking something that is
radically novel
like these are but that have realistic
pathways that are scientifically
rigorous
so how do we solve this problem we need
positive
inspirational visions
that are fundamentally realistic
but radically novel
it seems like an impossible solution or
possible problem
so i propose that we start with those
emerging innovative ideas those new ways
of living those transformational
projects those things that we call
bright spots or seeds of a good
anthropocene
so instead of envisioning what the
future looks like
why not start with the small experiments
that we see all the way around it around
us now those experiments that are
already in place
and imagine what the world might look
like if those were to grow
and come to fruition as larger
world shaping ideas
so why do it that way well radical
change often comes from these small
little seeds or experiments which are
present for long periods of time before
a bigger radical transformation occurs
so as william gibson said famously the
future is already here it's just
unevenly distributed
so what we're trying to do on our
project is take a step back look at
these little positive experiments
survey all of those innovations that are
happening
and wonder if we foster those if some of
them combine if they grow into something
that's bigger
how does that change the world what does
that world look like
so what is a seed
when i say a seed of a good anthropocene
so it's a way of thinking a way of doing
it could be an institution it could be a
technology
we require that they at least partially
exist at least in prototype form
these are things that are currently at
the margins they're not dominant
they have to contribute to a good
anthropocene at least according to
someone so recognize that even in a room
like this there are many different ideas
of what is good in a good anthropocene
and we have to be able to scale in some
way scale up scale out scale in or
somehow lead to a transformation that
goes beyond just the experimental
stage so i think of that as a pocket of
the better future in the present
that we want to grow and so our aim in
this project is to scope out some of
those radical changes
and especially some of the ones that go
beyond just incremental improvements
that are often the focus of today's
sustainability dialogue so we talk about
reducing pollution or increasing
environmental efficiency of agriculture
and i want to look at something that's a
little more radical than those
conversations
and my assumption is that many of these
seeds already exist in places around the
world
we're trying to identify where they
exist
and understand how they occur why they
occur
and how we might grow them and foster
them into something bigger
and by using these same seeds we've also
discovered that we can use these to
imagine how they push out into the
future and tell better stories to help
envision
positive realities and once you start
looking
these seeds are everywhere so i'm going
to tell you about a few examples just
because i find that that helps to give a
sense of what these things are so the
first one i'll start with
is a project called health and harmony
this was started by a doctor by the name
of keenery webb who went to indonesian
borneo
got really upset about the loss of
orangutan habitat there
go back to that one
and decided to do something about it and
so what health and harmony does is they
work with local communities she started
simply by spending a year just listening
to these communities and saying okay
we have a problem we're losing this
habitat
what what is going on here why is this
happening
so
spending your listening discovered that
people were
cutting down trees not because they
wanted to but because someone in their
family was getting sick their daughter
their mother their husband or wife
and they needed income to pay for
medical care
and as a doctor canery said ah i see a
solution to this
i will provide free or low cost health
care to any community that commits to
reducing deforestation
and so what have they seen
they see now
an over 60 decrease in illegal logging
and an increase in every human health
indicator that they measure in this
community after just five years
so the next example i want to talk about
is in copenhagen so the city of
copenhagen decided a few years ago
that they wanted to have organic food
offered in every public cafeteria so
every hospital every school every
government office
and as they started looking into how to
make their cafeterias organic they very
quickly discovered that they couldn't
simply serve the same meals it was far
too expensive to get or to get organic
meat
and so they started changing the menus
and the menus became more vegetarian the
menus became healthier
as the menus became healthier and more
vegetarian they started to realize oh
you know we've we've been cooking all of
this food centrally and then just
shipping it out to all of these
cafeterias where people are basically
just reheating it and serving it
let's train everybody to cook this food
in these local cafeterias and so after
just a few years now they've got
healthy
healthier food
that's being cooked
locally that's fresher that tastes
better in these cafeterias and that's
led to a whole bunch of other changes
that go far beyond just changes in their
in their cafeterias to changes in
waste stream management
and other things
and then one last one i'll talk about
songdo smart city this is a newly built
smart city from scratch
just outside of seoul south korea
this was built from scratch on about 600
hectares of reclaimed land it's got
over a hundred leed certified green
buildings and pneumatic waste disposal
system bike paths and computerized tech
throughout the entire city
to monitor all kinds of things energy
use traffic flow you name it they're
monitoring it
and it was built planned to be a sort of
corporate headquarters with all of this
efficient infrastructure easy air access
across asia
but it turns out
lots of korean families are saying wow
that's that's a really nice place to
live
um and and and moving there and so that
to me shows a nice technological example
that it's possible to build these really
attractive low-impact cities that
incorporate a lot of built
infrastructure
that are urban but that have are are
sort of also incorporating a lot of
ecological functioning in a way that's
really socially uh
vibrant
so those are three examples and and
luckily it turns out the world is full
of these experiments of people trying
things like this uh all over the world
and so in this
project that that we've
been doing we have collected over 500 of
these examples from all around the world
through a participatory process where
we've reached out to
mostly
scientists and activists
all around the world to get some
examples of these so
i'll say just uh stay tuned for the end
of my talk to find out how you can
submit your example
um
so a quick word about the seeds
the game here is pluralism novelty and
radicalism so the idea is not to define
a single good anthropocene or to try to
get consensus on whether one is possible
or what it looks like but to explore the
vastness of this idea space and increase
the diversity of conversations that
we're having about
the good anthropocene and whether it's
possible so we're really aiming for
pluralism capturing lots of ideas about
what makes a good future
that sort of diversity and novelty is
often really downplayed in the global
scientific models and global scientific
scenarios but we know that diversity is
essential for resilient thriving
ecosystems
and then we want the sort of radicalism
we need new stories and therefore we
need new kinds of seeds so pluralism
novelty and radicalism
and when we look at the database that we
have uh
have developed we get this real
diversity of initiatives that are listed
here around this circle in which we've
clustered them into different colors or
different
uh ideas and these include different
things like novel technologies
to
reduce ecological footprints it includes
efforts to increase sustainability of
food production improve equitable access
to resources to education and power
and novel educational formats that help
transform world views
and of the ones we've collected so far
we find six different clusters which are
showing to us that a lot of these seeds
address a number of critical issues
around ideas about
green urban transformation about
fairness about links between
food and biodiversity
about urbanism and urban transformation
as well as efforts to create change that
will help us remain within planetary
boundaries
so
if we imagine ourselves in this kind of
now here
where we've come from the past and all
the evidence is
that over history and especially over
the last 50 years we have caused a lot
of environmental
decline in environmental quality
even as human well-being has increased
and on average it has increased over the
last 50 years the sort of paradox of
environmental decline and human
well-being increase but if we imagine
ourselves at this moment of coming from
the past and heading into the future
how do we use the seeds to tell stories
of good anthropocenes rather than
stories of dystopian collapse because we
don't currently have a good model of how
to move forward in a way that's good for
people and planet that's good for humans
and nature so this is what we hope for
from putting the seeds together
so let me talk about our idea about how
these seeds can grow and change so we
think that the seeds can scale in a
number of different ways so for one
thing they can scale up
which means that they might grow in
place to be larger and larger so maybe
you know of an example that started in
neighborhood and became something done
by a whole city so for example in
montreal where i come from there was a
small pilot project in one neighborhood
to collect organic waste and compost it
and that's grown to something now that
the city is trying to do across the the
entire island of millions of people
so seeds can also scale out that is they
can leap to new places by replicating so
for example transition towns or
transition town totnes which was a
community-led local run charity they
were developed to try to strengthen
local economy and reduce environmental
impact especially focused on on peak oil
and building resilience for a future
with cheaper energy and with changing
climate
and they developed a range of different
projects
and that has now become the transition
network which is a collection of over a
thousand different towns in 40 different
countries that are doing something
similar
and they can also scale deep
so that is for example when a seed
creates new types of change so i'll go
again to montreal uh centro por roulon
which is an award-winning community
organization that started as a sort of
meals on wheels
the organization is now using food to
break isolation and build bridges
between individuals and especially
focusing on intergenerational
uh interaction and now they focus a
number of different agriculture and
farming operations that get people of
all generations involved in growing food
together
and finally seeds can interact and in
some cases seeds might enhance
one another and in other cases where the
visions of the future are fundamentally
different
there might be be
negative interactions where one seed
might reduce the capability of another
to grow and thrive and change
okay
so using our database we're now
developing a new method for thinking
starting from these seeds thinking about
how they might grow and scale to develop
a new kind of scenario a novel inductive
story-driven scenario that starts from a
handful of bright spots
and then imagines how those might face
critical futures
and critical challenges of the
anthropocene and thrive
so because the bright spots themselves
are diverse we end up with scenarios
that more easily represent a diversity
of views about what a good anthropocene
might might look like
and because the bright spots already
exist
the scenarios that we're developing we
think tend to be more realistic in their
pathways of how the future
comes about so i'll show you a few
pictures from a recent scenario
development exercise that we ran
in sweden where we focused on northern
european futures
we had participants from all across
northern europe and we focused on having
uh not only scientists there but also
writers artists activists uh
entrepreneurs who had started seeds
and a really diverse group of people
so what we did was we started by
building these things called future
wheels and what you see here in yellow
each yellow
post-it there is a bright spot
in this particular case i think we have
health and harmony is one of the bright
spots we have a technological bright
spot of self-driving cars
and we have a bright spot of
a sort of
organic agriculture
and we asked people to imagine if these
bright spots were in their most mature
format so if these bright spots were
spread throughout the world
what does the world look like and so
what you see here in blue was our first
set of
ideas about the future and then that has
follow-on effects in red
and follow-on effects after that and
then we imagine how those
three seeds are interacting and from
that we develop these images of positive
futures
so but then we need to figure out how do
we get there so this is how we
imagine getting there we go back and
forth
through time
with these three horizons so let me
explain this just a little bit so the
first horizon here now which starts up
high and goes low
on that y-axis is strategic fit so the
first horizon is stuff that fits really
well with the way the world works now
this is the business as usual
but you can see by that decline it's
things that we think are a bad fit with
our imagined positive futures
to the contrary the third horizon is our
pockets of the future that are embedded
in the present those are the emerging
patterns that are going to be the
long-term successor to the first horizon
right now they're just on the fringes
they're appearing and growing on the
fringes of the present system developing
new ways of meeting emergent conditions
and possibilities and so some dominant
pattern is going to emerge but in the
process of developing this we've got
many different future ideas sort of
jumbling around in that third horizon
and then the second horizon is this
turbulent domain
of transition
this is transitions and innovations
things that people are trying out in
response to
the changing landscape between the first
and third horizons and the second
horizon turns out to be really important
because that provides the disruptions
that are needed for the more radical
third horizon things to emerge and for
some of the the
first horizon systems to to disappear
and so what we do is take some of our
ideas about how the future might play
out and we work forwards and backwards
along this first horizon third horizon
until we're able to develop
a storyline that gets us from today
from the futures that we have right now
to our vision of how the future might
work with those future wheels starting
from our from our bright spots and what
we hope is that we get uh realistic
pathways
to radical futures
okay
so in this particular instance in in
northern uh europe we developed four
different stories that featured things
like rewilding the radical listening
that came from health and harmony
value shifts transparent local
governance more time to spend with
family more time to engage in civic
governance
more connection between people and
nature decentralization of power and
decline of
in the power of corporations in
particular
because we have these diverse bright
spots we get this sort of diverse view
of what a good anthropocene
might look like
and because we work through this first
horizon third horizon framework to trace
what new things we need to get to that
world and what old things need to go
away really helps you to see the
pathways
um for so for example in these scenarios
the use of technology to free up time
and resources and in one of the
scenarios for example
uh that started with self-driving cars
that became an important vehicle that
freed up people's time
and that time along with value shifts
led to changes in the way that people
interacted with each other which led to
changes in governance which led to what
we called radical listening councils
which were basically local governments
way of organizing themselves
once we had that
sort of local
radical listening counsel
we then realized well we need we needed
the well which was the world
environmental learning library which was
a way that all of these different local
communities could connect to one another
and share information about how they
were solving problems so that
communities didn't become
isolated and small in their thinking but
rather became
broad and expansive in their in their
thinking and that's just one of the
scenarios other scenarios that we
developed featured innovative finance
novel economic systems massive rewilding
projects or other
indigenous community-led transformation
we got this really broad variety of
different uh of different scenarios
and we're trying out other methods um as
well so we have some
old style dungeons and dragons kinds of
games with dice
that we're using with the bright spots
to help people sort of mash different
bright spots together and ask what
worlds uh emerge we've got some games
that we're playing with uh with virtual
reality
we have a series of different board
games that we're playing uh in locations
all around the world
and even an online
sim city style
game that was an audience award nominee
called
anthrocratos
which was about playing an online sort
of sim city game to to imagine the
future
and we've done these in a variety of
ways in a variety of different places
around the world we've done them in in
asia africa in europe
we have plans to expand now to north and
south america and now that we're
starting to build this set of scenarios
we can compare them so we can learn what
is the same and what's different in the
ways that people think about a good
anthropocene and explore a variety of
different pathways to get to some of
these
anthropocenes
so beyond telling these stories one
other thing that we're doing with
with this database of 500 seeds is
thinking about change so in other words
what makes the seeds scale some of them
scale some of them scale up they scale
out they scale deep some of them thrive
some of them emerge they seem like great
ideas and then they fade and go away
and with our database of 500 of them we
can explore what is it about
local political systems or local
governance or institutions that help
some of these thrive while others go
away what is it about leadership what is
it about the ideas or how those ideas
work with or against the kinds of
problems that are that people are facing
that either
fuel articulation of new ideas and
change people's experience
in consolidate into a new regime or that
leads some to be squeezed out by other
macro structures and and go
away okay
so let me just end by coming back to
this idea of living in the anthropocene
of exiting the holocene and living in
this new uh
new
world and let me argue once again that
in this new world
we need a new way of living on a planet
we need a way of living on the planet
that's good for nature and people
together
and that's a subtle but fundamentally
really important shift in the way that
we look at this problem
and i hope that i've convinced you
tonight that developing truly innovative
and inspiring scenarios about how that
might happen how we might get to a world
that is good for people in nature
but scenarios that remain grounded in
reality that that's a critical challenge
for us in the global community
and we're going to need radically new
visions about the human place
but
luckily there are people already working
on this
all around us right now in ways big
and small
they are creating seeds that we think
can grow into a good anthropocene
so i want to thank people who have
come to scenario development workshops
like this one
especially
thank
my fellow leaders of this
project who come from all around the
world and have been developing this idea
and invite you to contribute
your seed at our website so that we can
change direction so that we don't end up
where we're heading
thanks
[Applause]
i take it you're still collecting seeds
judging by that last name i'll never
stop collecting seeds so what are some
of the most recent that kind of got your
uh got your interest
well i i'm i'm really interested in that
um
that health and harmony one really
stands out to me as a as a systems
scientist because
what i like about that one is
and what i think is so powerful about it
is
um at some point of time people living
in that forest would have
had there would have been a connection
between human health and forest health
in a in a world where that
system was just local people would have
been
their health depended on the health of
the forest around them and that at some
point with global trade that connection
gets gets broken and they're more
dependent on being able to buy health
care from somewhere else and what i like
about what health and harmony did was
they just sort of came in and drew that
feedback back in and said nope you want
to have healthy people you got to keep a
healthy forest and they just put that
feedback back in to create a better
system and a lot of the ones
when i look at them a lot of the ones
that are
hugely successful feature that kind of
thinking about system dynamics and that
was that one scaling yet
they're right now looking for new places
to work and they're thinking more about
scaling the same idea to other
uh to other places
it's in indonesia or where they're in
in indonesia yeah in borneo
okay that's one what else
um so other ones that i like
in particular are any ones
and there's a lot of them so i won't
name names that are
that have started by thinking that they
were going to connect people to nature
and a lot of those
are
gardening projects or
farming or
restoration projects and and often what
i'll hear these groups say is well i
thought that what i was doing was was
helping people connect to nature that's
outside their doorway but but what it
turned out that i did was i connected
people to other people and and now those
people now that they're connected
they're doing other things they're
getting politically active or they're
you know changing other things and so
it's again an example of
how how creating one connection creates
possibility for scaling and lots of
other connections
so you mentioned the well which is a
nice name
and
not my idea
the idea is to have these seeds
basically communicating with one another
is that already happening through you
guys or any way or how does that work
only in the sense so so we've created
some situations where a few of the seeds
can come together so when we run the the
on-the-ground scenario development
workshops like the ones that i talked
about in northern europe where we do
this first horizon second horizon third
horizon
we always bring
a number of seed entrepreneurs to those
workshops to represent their seeds and a
big draw for those folks is often
connecting with some of the other seeds
so that they can say hey how did you
solve this problem or how do you deal
with you know when the local
government's getting in your way
but those so far have been pretty small
and what we'd love to do is have you
know a seed could we have a confluence
where we can create a gathering of
hundreds or even thousands of these seed
entrepreneurs because they they have so
many
ideas about how to solve problems and
often they're facing the same kinds of
problems so that sort of idea
convocation sort of regional everybody
in south asia that's doing stuff
and some of them kind of uh
similar in kind so they're actually all
doing stuff with cities or something
like that right both kinds and then
once every some number of years the big
convocation where they'll come together
and go crazy
yeah
yeah or across different regions you
know all the ones that are thinking
about technology but from all different
parts of the world you can imagine lots
of ways of doing it
question from kevin kelly have you back
checked your method by surveying seeds
25 or 50 years ago
and how prophetic were the seeds of 25
to 50 years i was around for some of
those seeds
yeah so we so we have not done that and
one of the things that i i think we
haven't yet done a very good job of even
within our database is to look at is
even to collect seeds that haven't
worked because you can learn a lot from
the ones that that haven't worked but
people don't like to talk about those
so much they want to talk about their
stuff that has worked so that's is one
of our next steps
we had a few that are pinched out we've
had a few that haven't that haven't
worked for sure and we've had a few
because of the way that we have
collected them you know we've had a few
that that somebody says you know this is
a great
new idea and then somebody else says
that's actually maybe a land grab by a
foreign interest so we've had some that
you know are they seeds are they not
seeds
um
not entirely clear
well i was around for the communes which
were sure they were all seeds but much
better civilization and almost all of
them pinched out for kind of
soap operatic reasons by and large
yep
the one some of the ones that that
persisted for a while actually were
based around uh some kind of religious
practice
does any of that play into the ones
you're looking at
i haven't looked very closely at
uh the religion and it's it it doesn't
stand out for me as being prominent in
the ones that we've collected so far and
you notice when you look at the map we
also haven't
got a great geographic spread in part
because of how we've we've built them so
you know australia appears empty of of
bright spots it's not actually empty
it's just that we haven't gotten a good
job of getting there yet i was just sort
of riffing on the question by austin
aaronsberg who says what role does
religion play in storytelling about
environmental stewardship
and
you know the bible has some stuff about
dominion that's tricky but hey we got
dominion guess what played out
and some had some stuff about
stewardship
um
and creation and protecting creation and
things like that
um on the other hand christians have not
been always that great about taking care
of nature
uh what do you got and is there anything
in there i mean animism should we
start
there's been a lot of tree worship going
on is that the right thing to do yeah
i'm trying to think if we have any seeds
that are that
i don't think we have any that emerge
from that strong religious
feeling and certainly there's been a lot
of arguing back and forth over whether
that
that stewardship has been
a positive or not so positive role in
the way we see our place on the planet
so the um
fun to see chick collinboxycotopia up
there
and a lot of this really sounds
ecotopian to me and it sounds kind of
left liberal
a lot of it so tell me about some seeds
that make liberals squirm but by god
they're onto something yeah so we we
have had a hard time getting a lot of
seeds that make liberals there are some
and i think you know to some extent some
of the technology and some of the sort
of top-down control and there are some
of those
you know tend to make us kind of you
know say more what's a what's the
technology one that makes you squirm but
they might be onto something let's see a
technology one that makes me squirm so
there are a fair number that are sort of
you know gmo oriented or
uh
you know
meat you know
invented meat
development that you know
i'm not so sure but i but i like to play
those out because it forces me to think
about
you know what is my place and what do i
think and and how do these play out i'm
in in the one that i that i talked about
with well with these self-driving cars
um you know i was at first like
self-driving cars
you know i didn't like that so much but
you built the whole thing around it but
we built the whole thing and it turned
out you know it was it played an
important role in how that story played
out because it changed the way people
were
interacting with each other it changed
the way people got from place to place
and it changed the way people got things
from place to place so the self-driving
cars meant that people could have more
sharing economy because they could just
put stuff in the car and it could move
from one party to the next party so
every community could have their party
supplies instead of every person having
party supplies and that that sort of
fundamentally changed everything and it
wasn't
you know when people first said
self-driving cars to me i just thought
oh more cars yeah you know but it but it
turned out it wasn't it didn't work like
that so it was a surprising one to me
self-driving cars want to engage
agriculture because one of the people
you quoted are well as we both know
and earl's pretty strong on that uh
drastically productive efficient
agriculture precision agriculture with
you know tractors that know what they're
doing and they're sensing the soil and
putting in just the right amount of
which fertilizer not water seeds that
are separated with just the amount of
distance all this kind of stuff which is
basically robots
uh instead of
loving the land soulful
people it's it's
robots who actually you can
train them to act soulful but
they're robots
is that okay
so
besides doing this
work my my other hat is i work on
agricultural systems
and my experience there is that
efficiency has not been good for us
um efficiency has led us down a road
with agriculture where we
we basically engineer systems to be
tighter and tighter and more and more
controlled which makes them much less
resilient and adaptable so we get
systems that just don't have the kind of
flex that
i think we're going to need as we head
out of the holocene and into the
anthropocene we're going to need systems
that
can change and adapt and we we have
fundamentally built in agriculture that
is not very adaptable it depends on
subsidies and efficiency
and the sort of more crop per drop
mentality and that that has not been
very good for us
mary mangan uh online asks if somebody
in cahokia was asked to do the
experiment on visionary uh around some
promising seeds what would have been
that have been
for them and how did it play out cahokia
faded
uh
cahokia faded for for
you know
a lot of unknown reasons but i know i'm
not weird it's still unknown
getting on it researchers we need to
know what the hell happened right there
it's pretty cool if you haven't been i
highly recommend going religion that
often takes down
back to religion um
you know what's hard for me to
picture is
the kokokians
predicting or at least putting into
their scenarios the arrival of europeans
which undoubtedly must have played a
major
role if cahokia was still around
and i just can't imagine how
you come up with that in a scenario
which makes me think that even the
stories that we tell now we are gonna
fundamentally we're gonna miss things
but but my hope is that
you know as with the global scenario
development community it's a way of
staying on your feet if you if you
aren't picturing there's only one way
the future is going to unfold but you
think oh there's this range of
possibilities even if you're wrong
you're more likely to adapt more quickly
because you've already thought about
multiple
possibilities so
you know even if we don't catch all of
the things that are going to happen or
predict it exactly right i think that
will create hope and will create a sort
of flexibility and adaptability that
that i think is going to be critical
one of your uh charts that i loved that
you had at the beginning of sort of the
sequence of how we were thinking about
nature the last four or five decades i
could have used in the talk i gave last
week
but it's interesting because you said
the progression of four stage is sort of
one per decade and right now we're at
people and nature
but that rate of change suggested
last about 10 years and we got a whole
you know 10 000 to 450 million years to
go yet
uh
do you think that's the last shift or is
it trending somewhere
i i sure hope it's the last shift
um
but that's what the previous group hoped
too
did they i wonder if the people who were
thinking about
nature for people
yeah they thought maybe consistent
services you know we do the math we do
the economics
and uh in costa rica and places like
that
uh you just get the water and all the
things that you want to have sort of
covered and you get the government to go
along with accounting for it in an
economic way
that all would be well
what happened
well it doesn't work so nicely like that
oops
i mean sometimes it does but it but it
but it doesn't always and i think you
know there's a lot of arguments for for
needing something that is
more grounded i think sometimes it it it
does
help to think about
benefits that we're getting from from
nature
it certainly helps us to think about
things in a more multifaceted
way
um
yeah i don't know where we're going
people and nature to
well you know the breakthrough institute
over in berkeley he likes to talk about
decoupling and early in the thick of
that basically
the the less we do basically any kind of
exploitation of nature the better
and that's a bit of a separation as
opposed to complete immersion
um are there some cases of seeds that
have that quality
yeah there are some that have that
quality
it's hard for me to imagine
that we can decouple in that that way i
just think there's there's just too
many of us let's say in the the world of
half earth
you know who's half
it's not going to be the rich white
people half
that gets given away so it's it's hard
for me to imagine how that plays out in
a way that goes to a positive
to a truly positive anthropocene
so
one of the diagrams i really loved was
the one you started with basically the
the whole scene temperature change uh
just basically minute temperature
changes versus the previous many tens of
thousands of years or it was all over
the place
um
and humanity and agriculture and
civilization has basically happened in
that nice weather period
um
do you think that's over now and we are
going to be looking at those kinds of
temperature crises indefinitely
the storms of my grandchildren i think
is the title of
you know yeah i mean i i remember so
clearly the first time i ever saw that
graph i just about fell out of my chair
because it hadn't occurred to me that oh
right everything we know happens
in that period of stability um
so what i didn't show in that graph is
at the end
um if if you sort of zoom in on that end
it it goes like this so it doesn't go
back to
to up and down it just goes up so i
don't know whether we're headed to
back to instability or we're just headed
up into the stratosphere with that but
we're headed out of that stability
that's for sure
um i suspect you have an opinion about
geoengineering
of
a variable changing
opinion
um
my my gut instinct is is danger lies
that that direction and so proceed with
extreme caution
um
but i
there are some examples of like oh okay
well
what is what does that look like at
smaller scales i'm a little more
comfortable when it's when it looks like
experiments and when it comes with a lot
of monitoring to understand you know
what are we doing
what's the effect of this and then
really thinking about
time lags and delays because we're not
you know
the effects aren't always immediately
apparent and so we don't want to miss
something because we've measured you
know right afterwards or right nearby we
want to really monitor broadly well it
sounds like monitoring and and the smart
city that you were pointing out
had all kinds of sensors all over the
city watching everything all the time
and it looks like one of the things
that's coming on is a whole lot more
capability of sensing what's going on
not only with us but what's going on
and i take it you're all for that
yes if we're thinking smartly about it
right so it's one thing to monitor and
just collect all that data and put it in
a dusty binder somewhere and it's
another thing to take that information
and really think about what it's telling
us and think about time lag so you know
we've been talking about adaptive
management of ecosystems for a long time
now where we basically you know
treat management like experiments try
something and see what happens try
something and see what happens
to me that monitoring data is is
important but only if
we're using it to see what the effects
are of what we're doing and then
adjusting based on that otherwise
why bother should that data be publicly
available
oh my goodness
um for lots of people who do see like
things with it
i mean i think it depends what sort of
data if you're talking about someone's
personal data about where they're going
then
the animals and the trees and the
weather and detail and stuff like that i
mean i think a lot of it we can only win
by making information
available for people to
i just got a flash of people freaking
out about collars on animals that they
were invading their privacy
and
in a sense we are but if one if they
don't mind it too if it helps us protect
their
the habitat that they turns out they
need then that's probably not a bad
thing
yeah i mean it depends a lot what
what data we're collecting and what
we're doing with it and at what scale
you know are you making every individual
piece available are you sort of
collecting and anime anonymizing things
i mean you don't want for example
information available on where uh the
last rhinoceroses are so that the
poachers can go you know hey i got it
they're right there on the gps i just
got to get there
you know there's some there's some
danger for sure in that too fair point
alyssa asks what seed do you feel is
essential to a good anthropocene that
you haven't
been able to find yet but you're looking
hard
huh
um
you know just the the talk about
monitoring i i haven't
seen in the seeds at least not that i
can think of it's hard for me to have
all 500 of them on recall but i haven't
seen ones
that are
focused on that kind of data monitoring
and
um and understanding and and that seems
like that would be
critical because at least in my vision
of this positive future
there is adapting and flexibility and
movement all the time and changing
and that would require there to be a
seed out there that is doing that kind
of monitoring and and then suggesting
what sort of adaptation we need how do
we need to move flex
i don't
think that we have one that looks like
that
well planet labs here in town is doing
you know sort of daily earth
yeah considerable detail actually
they're a great example
and
this is a um
a frame of reference that you're
developing
that
invites the kind of sort of ground-based
experience-based scenario planning that
you're doing
and is that really moving in the
direction of of storytelling of people
engaging at the story level
well i'm not sure i understand
is there a book coming out of this first
um
not at the moment
can people look somewhere and see the
500 and see what they are yeah so people
can can see on our website you can see
where we we don't have all 500 up
because we don't have the database up
but we
we post seeds and stories about them
that are a little bit longer form so you
get more than just the information
that's in the database so you can look
at those
eventually you can look at the 500 what
we don't have
collected in any sort of way that that
people could access it yet is all the
different stories
that are coming out so we now have
dozens of different stories because
we've run these workshops in different
parts of the world and that i think
would be quite
interesting for purposes of comparison
and and
you know
looking at how those are different in
the same region what's
with an s.net good anthropocenes yep
yeah because there's plurality
that involves other planets right
not just many stories
um i don't like to think that that
there's one
vision of how this is going to unfold
and we're not trying to predict
the one positive pathway i think there's
a lot of positive pathways
out there to choose from for a radical
seed maker i can imagine them
scrolling through the
not quite 500 yet c's that they can
examine and if they're going to be
radical they'll okay okay that's been
tried that's been tried that's concerned
that's been tried
and then they can imagine themselves but
nobody's tried x
and be motivated to go get uh weird
yeah so so
yeah you could do that i think a lot of
times a lot of the ones that i see are
people notice somebody notices a problem
or somebody notices a sort of space
that's not occupied
which could be a physical space you know
a schoolyard or a or a you know roadside
between the the sidewalk and the road
that's not being used it says
i could do something with that space or
or a virtual space that somebody's not
occupying in that community in their
community of connecting one thing to
another thing and it seems like a lot of
them emerge from
from that
from 500 down to 5 000 on to a great
many good anthropocenes thank you elena
for doing this thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
you